hey guys my name is just this is Dan and
you are watching games but news to find
out what went on gaming today let's tell
them about it
man we need rehearse these better
let's start you off with some good news
Nintendo has said they're bringing back
the NES classic and extending the supply
of the SNES classic what's that do you
assemble thousand scalpers all crying at
once the NES classic Edition will return
to shelves in North America and Europe
sometime next summer no other details
were provided though it's probably safe
to assume its roster of 30 games and
price of $59.99 will stay the same the
NES classic Edition launched in November
of last year and sold out almost
immediately the lack of supply led to a
lucrative scalping market with some
units fetching over 300 bucks on sites
like eBay when Nintendo announced the
SNES classic they made a point of
mentioning that supply would be
increased this time around
apparently they drastically
underestimated demand again with
pre-orders way outstripping supply to
combat this Nintendo have decided to
extend the availability of the SNES
classic from end of year 2017 into 2018
you can grab the new console that comes
with the unreleased star fox 2 from
September 29th we'll be sure to keep you
updated on any developments on this one
so please don't go and spend too much
money on scalped units
next up journey developer that game
company has announced a new game for
mobile I'll swear I was looking for
something a play on my face oh it's only
for Apple once you'll be able to play
sky on your iPhone iPad or Apple TV
where everything can be done with one
finger using the Siri remote the game
was shown off during Apple's keynote
it's a multiplayer social game where up
to 8 players can explore the world above
the clouds hopefully it's a little more
family-friendly than that other world
above the clouds Columbia I'd say so
yeah players take control of the
children of light and their goal is to
bring the light where it is need at the
most this appears to be done through
exploring and finding hidden areas sky
will feature an orchestral soundtrack
and is scheduled to launch this winter
finally an HD remaster of action
adventure a commie is arriving with 4k
support on PC ps4 and Xbox one
Capcom has officially announced that
that dog Zelda game that all of your
friends keep telling you to play will
release on modern consoles and PC on
December 12 you can grab it digitally
for 20 bucks and a physical ps4 version
will also be available in a press
release Capcom stated Okami HD will be
compatible with Xbox one X and ps4 Probe
whilst featuring stunning 4k graphics on
Xbox one x ps4 pro and supported PC
hardware you'll also be able to choose
with
playing in widescreen sixteen by nine
all the games original four by three
aspect ratio the loading screen
minigames that were absent from the ps3
and Wii version rear releases will also
be available this time around and allow
you to earn bonus diamond things which
can be traded in for in-game items
release on ps2 in 2006 akame came from
the now-defunct division of Capcom also
responsible for beautiful Joe it
garnered universal acclaim thanks to its
stunning at painting inspired visuals
and zelda light gameplay economy was
released with motion controls for Wii in
2008 and received a sequel a comedy on
DS in 2011 let us know if you keen on
picking this one up in the comments
below that's everything we have for you
today enjoy the rest of your day and
we'll see you guys tomorrow Thursday and
Friday for all the news that you'll ever
need I had a dream that we were debating
what were the most popular soundtracks
of all time and I was like you me and
Eddie and Eddie kept ain't you kept
saying the Batman soundtrack like it's
because of Prince the Batman soundtrack
and I was like what about the bodyguard